hello and welcome to multivariable
calculus so I think I should probably
start off by addressing the elephant in
the living room Here I am sadly not Sal
but I'm still going to teach you some
math my name is grant I'm pretty much a
Matheny estai enjoy making animations of
things when applicable and boy is that
applicable when it comes to
multivariable calculus so the first
thing we got to get straight is what is
this word multivariable that separates
calculus as we know it from the new
topic that you're about to study well I
could say it's all about multi variable
functions that doesn't really answer
anything because what's a multi variable
function and basically the kinds of
functions that we're used to dealing
with in the old world in the ordinary
calculus world will have a single input
some kind of number as their input and
then outputs just a single number and
you would call this a single variable
function basically because that guy
there is the single variable so then a
multi variable function is something
that handles multiple variables so you
know it's common to write it as like X Y
it doesn't really matter what letters to
use and it couldn't it could be you know
X Y Z x1 x2 x3 a whole bunch of things
but just to get started we often think
just two variables and this will output
something that depends on both of those
commonly it'll output just a number so
you might imagine a number that depends
on x and y in some way like x squared
plus y but it could also output a vector
right so you could also imagine
something that's got multiplied variable
input f of X Y and it outputs something
that also has multiple variables like I
mean I'm just making stuff up here 3x
and you know 2y and this isn't set in
stone but the convention is to usually
think if there's multiple numbers that
go into the output think of it as a
vector if there's multiple numbers that
go into the input just kind of write
them write them more sideways like this
and think of them as a point in space
because I mean when you look at
something like this and you've got an X
and you've got a Y you could think about
those as two separate numbers you know
here's your number line with the point X
on it somewhere maybe that's five maybe
that's three it doesn't really matter
and then you've got another number line
and it's Y and you can think of them as
separate entities
but it would probably be more accurate
to call it multi-dimensional calculus
because really instead of thinking of
you know X and y is separate entities
whenever you see two things like that
you're going to be thinking about the XY
plane and thinking about just a single
point and you think of this as a
function that takes a point to a number
or a point to a vector and a lot of
people when they start teaching multi
variable calculus they just jump into
the calculus and there's lots of fun
things partial derivatives gradients
good stuff that you'll learn but I think
first of all I want to spend a couple
videos just talking about the different
ways we visualize the different types of
multivariable functions
so as a sneak peek I'm just going to go
through a couple of them really quickly
right now just so you kind of whet your
appetite and see what I'm getting at but
the next few videos are going to go
through them in in much much more detail
so first of all graphs when you have
multivariable functions graphs become
3-dimensional but these only really
apply to functions that have some kind
of two-dimensional input which you might
think about as living on this XY plane
and a single number as their output and
the height of the graph is going to
correspond with that output like I said
you'll be able to learn much more about
that in the dedicated video on it but
these functions also can be visualized
just in two dimensions flattening things
out where we visualize the entire input
space and associate a color with each
point so this is the kind of thing where
you you know you'd have some function
that's got a two-dimensional input B f
of X Y and what we're looking at is the
XY plane all of the input space and this
outputs just some number you know maybe
it's like x-squared this particular one
is in x-squared but you know that and
maybe some complicated thing and the
color tells you roughly the size of that
output and the lines here called contour
lines tell you which inputs all share a
constant output value and again I'll go
into much more detail there these are
really nice much more convenient than
three dimensional graphs to just sketch
out moving right along
I'm also going to talk about surfaces in
three-dimensional space
they look like graphs but they actually
deal with a much different animal that
you could think of it as mapping to
dimensions and I like to sort of push it
about and we've got kind of a two
dimensional input that somehow moves
into three dimensions and you're just
looking at what the output of that looks
like I'm not really caring about how
gets there these are called parametric
surfaces another fun one is a vector
field where every input point is
associated with some kind of vector
which is the output of the function
there so this would be a function with a
two-dimensional input and then
two-dimensional output because each of
these are two-dimensional vectors and
the fun part with these guys is that you
can just kind of imagine a fluid flowing
so here's a bunch of droplets like water
and they kind of flow along that and
that actually turns out to give insight
about the underlying function it's one
of those beautiful aspects of
multivariable calculus of exposure to
that again I'm just sort of zipping
through to whet your appetite don't
worry if this doesn't make sense
immediately and one of my all-time
favorite ways to think about
multivariable functions is to just take
the input space in this case this is
going to be a function that inputs
points in two-dimensional space
and watch them move to their output so
this is going to be a function that also
outputs in two dimensions and I'm just
going to watch every single point move
over to where it's supposed to go
these can be kind of complicated to look
at or to think about it first but as you
as you gain a little bit of thought and
exposure to them they're actually very
nice and it provides a beautiful
connection with linear algebra a lot of
you out there if you're studying
multivariable calculus you either are
about to study linear algebra or you
just have or maybe you're doing it
concurrently but understanding functions
as transformations is going to be a
great way to connect those two so with
that I'll stop jabbering through these
topics really quickly and in the next
few videos I'll actually go through them
in detail and hopefully you can get a
good feel for what multivariable
functions can actually feel like